if you
are wearing rings as i do it's a good
idea to take them off
because when you prepare the dough it's
not great
it's not very hydrating if you are
wearing rings
i once lost a stone
very safe either but you want to of
course
wash the vegetables okay the broccoli
you can just
cut them into small pieces and maybe you
can make a small
sofrito with the alga
that's one option the
spinach you can just use them as they
are
in the pepperoni you need to wash them
cut them remove the seeds
and then you can cut them in stripes for
example
that's a good thing and again you can
put them in the
pan so they roast a little bit
a tiny bit of oil you can do the same
thing
i like them cut longitudinally but if
you want to cut them
in disks that's fine and look
for the melon it's a little bit more
complex but not too much
so you want to cut it in disks
as see as thin as you can so it cooks
fast yeah yes
okay we got it and then you first put it
with a little bit of salt
um in the sink because the idea is that
you want
the bitter to go away sometimes the
eggplants can be a little bit bitter
then you have to rinse it very well dry
it
and then just roast it on the pan high
fire
for short times that's it
okay we wash them
cut them in the shape that you prefer
i recommend to do small slices
because again they cook faster and if
you want
you can saute them for example with
chipotle
so this is the vegetable team
the other team will
start preparing pizza
pizza you'll need
um
i will help you with this and then we
will add
some whatever
so don't forget that i'm giving you very
precise measurements but this is only
because it's the first time that you're
making pizza
once you have done pizza if you're
trying for a few times you won't need
la bilancia the scale anymore you will
do everything
yes okay bye
i'm gonna put the two events at two
different temperatures so they see the
result
cooking the pizza at 400 fahrenheit and
500 paranoids
you were
right so you want the dough
to be to stick together but you don't
want it to be sticky
start with not too much then you don't
have to worry
if the dough becomes too sticky
and then i was telling them you can take
it out of
the bowl that you're using the measuring
cup
and you can mix it on the counter
you just put it on you wait
a little bit more water
don't worry you don't have to be
delicate you can be
strong with the pizza i'll show you now
the
this isn't much dough you can
you can either
mix it this way and then you can make
the circle movement
with your palm you see
good and yeah you can probably add
and we make
so that we can make large rectangles
your fingers
okay in this way we are sure that there
are no bubbles in the dough
so we put the pasta
and then you put mozzarella as much as
little
spice and you're gonna put the toppings
your favorite toppings everything is
allowed
sprinkle them with oregano you put
a couple of spoonful of olive oil on
each
pizza and a pinch of
salad okay pasta
also stopping we put it at the very
end we don't put it the basilico
it doesn't taste good look at troy look
at troy
okay oh we're not gonna make more yes
we're gonna make smart
no no no you guys and we'll help
yourself could we add some colors
oh
they are very very tasty the taste is
very intense so you don't
need maybe if you want to put them you
can also cut them
and like little pieces in different
locations because if you taste it if you
take a whole lot
it's good but not everybody like likes
it because
the taste is kind of intense if you want
to use the prosciutto
um
the top is like 400 fahrenheits and the
bottom one at 500
they will cook differently i made it on
purpose so that you can
decide like what you like best everybody
has a different taste
you can experiment you can make
different thicknesses of the pizza
and you can bake them at the different
temperatures
another small detail i give you the
temperature in fahrenheit because
that's what we have here in italy
the temperatures are in gravity
gradient
thank
oh
bye